in the hum
and heat of scrap metal kins
ghana's only professional glassblower
michael tete is at work
his blistered hands molding red hot
molten glass into delicate shapes
it becomes like my passion it's like my
heart
so all the time i want to blow glass and
glass is it's a wonderful work
you see how you are working with glass
is expanded and it's like life you see
yes it's like life
it is expand
life also expands it's like a journey
and to make that journey michael trolls
through accra scrapyards and landfills
he only uses recycled materials his
mission is to reduce ghana's glass waste
each year the country imports glass and
ceramic products worth nearly 300
million dollars
michael says most of it ends up in
landfills or on the streets
so recycling them makes sense
not just for the environment but also
for business
we don't want the the broken glasses to
be flowing around like that or they will
dump it in the landfill
and
if
we are using recycle
we can get money
he teaches ghanians the craft and
explains that they don't have to rely on
other countries to buy what they need
and his vision seems to be working
the youth they don't have work to do
if we establish this joke
they'll get more work to do and do not
sit and they will not sit down
michael says he wants to make ghana
beautiful
and to do it by transforming dangerous
waste into works of art made with
passion
priyanka gupta al jazeera